Wow a walking talking snowman you really  are alive hello  Olaf are these your friends hmm no never  met him  don't know anyone Bluegreen or without  these spiky that's amazing you can  control ice control it no all I ever do  is hurt people  yeah  [Music]  give me strength  [Music]  whoa  [Music]  still Sora that doesn't mean you should  change except the power you're given  find the hearts joined  [Music]  in a kingdom oh you're so what else  except light or darkness I know I want  to know me Roxas does exist his hearts  inside my heart in that case by all  things nothing would please us more than  Roxas is returned of course and Roxas  yes for the virtual world to be  completely realized it Ansem the wise  would have included Roxas is full data  in the construction  [Music]  this key plate is that Nikki you're too  late  [Music]  you